I'm the most recent bachelor re lion
dyke jr. and his fiancee Lauren Burnham
they're set to get married in January
well now they're expecting you see them
here they posted these pics to Instagram
that's Lauren holding a sonogram
announcing their pregnancy do we know a
due date for the baby this is just
coming in yes so the baby is due in June
and I know yet they have a wedding in
Hawaii in January they just bought a
home in Arizona so everything's really
coming together for them it's a joy to
watch especially after you know they're
kind of dramatic storyline that they got
wrapped in back in season we're playing
that down that he is basically known a
lot of people are calling him the worst
bachelor ever because he proposes to
Becca kufran then he goes and breaks up
with her and then he turns around and on
his own live season finale of proposed
to his runner-up Lauren Burnham but it's
but you know highs and lows and quick
back and forth with these two I mean now
they're together and within less than a
year of that finale pregnant
expecting and getting married I'll give
them this a lot of bachelor couples
don't end up getting married even though
they get engaged on the show and they're
really doing it getting married in
Hawaii in January that's sorry with
Becca kufran and that very controversial
season finale where you broke up with
her and then here he is proposing to
Lauren Burnham they got some scattered
applause during that and I don't blame
the horn for that it was just people
were more so a little turned off by
things already had done but now
expecting a bachelor baby and you know
what a baby is always a blessing so
congrats to them easy was actually
exclusively with the former bachelor and
his tux fitting for the wedding
just last month before this big news
broke and he was talking to us about
starting a family let's listen to that I
think that we're just trying to get
through this this little section
obviously the wedding such a huge part
of our lives and it's gonna be such a
beautiful day oh yeah we're excited to
start a family and and we've bought a
beautiful house and we're really
settling in in Arizona so yeah one step
at a time so things may be not going in
exactly the order he was talking about
here but the two seem super super happy
so congrats to them
[Music]
[Applause]